australia's bushland is still recovering
from the black summer fires that ripped
through the land a year ago
blackening 35 million hectares and
killing or displacing
nearly 3 billion animals soon after
logging was restarted in fire affected
state forests
many plant species and almost all animal
species simply can't deal with that
double disturbance in rapid succession
and that makes salvage logging or post
fire logging
the most detrimental form of logging
of all kinds of harvesting harvesting
standards were tightened after the fires
but in the south brumen state forest
locals found evidence of loggers
breaching their licence
allegedly cutting down large
hollow-bearing trees
which provide crucial shelter for
threatened species
authorities are investigating but
activists have continued their campaign
to end logging in the region we were
shocked we were just shocked that that
level of non-compliance was going on and
that
forestry corporation itself hadn't
picked it up the new south wales
forestry corporation says its operations
are sustainable and
carefully managed with forests
regenerating after being logged
but as the climate heats up so too has
debate
on the future of logging and how
australia is more broadly managing its
land
the world wildlife fund has listed
australia as a global hot spot for
deforestation
with land being cleared mainly for
agriculture
and farming whether it's land clearing
for farming or logging in state forests
like this one many environmentalists
believe
if australia is serious about action on
climate change
it needs to rethink how it manages its
bush land and forests
or they warn habitats and wildlife are
at risk
of irreparable damage recent research
has also found evidence that logging
native forests is making fires more
severe from debris
left behind and forests are important
sources of carbon storage
vital to reducing emissions it's the
greatest
source of carbon sink the the mature
trees
so without them what do we do
you know what are we going to do with
australian leaders under pressure to
address climate change the question will
be how the nation manages its land
while also balancing business interests
nicola gage aljazeera south bruman state
forest